hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over my favorite way
to attack
the french defense and that is the ortho
snap gambit the french defense starts
out with e4
e6 and this is my least favorite defense
to go up against is white i like to
start out with e4
quite a bit i'm an attacking player i
like to open up lines and get as much
material involved as possible
and attack my opponent all throughout
the game
french defense just never really enjoyed
playing against it but i
really do enjoy playing the ortho snap
gambit and really putting my opponent to
the test
and they also just seem to not know how
to play against it so if you're not
familiar with it
it starts out with c4 saying that yeah
if you want to play
d5 that's fine i now have an additional
pawn to take here
so after the pawn takes pawn recaptures
and then queen to b3 yes white has the
option pushing forward here to e5
if he doesn't want to give up his
central pawns you can always take here
on
d5 i can make videos on those variations
if you want to see that but queen
to b3 does give up material says go
ahead and take this pawn here on e4
in this video i am going to be going
over the accepted line of pawn taking
here on e4
and then white plays bishop to c4 and
you can see already the battery here
with the queen
and bishop on this long light square
diagonal attacking the square
here on f7 f7 square being a huge
weakness for black early on because the
king is the only piece
defending this square right here in this
video
we're going to be going over different
variations of how black may continue
some of them being how black actually
defends the square
in the description below i will have
links to all the variations so if you
want to skip ahead at any point
to those variations you can but we're
going to be going over
knight to h6 defending that if the queen
wants to defend it with queen to e7
or queen to d7 we're also going to be
taking a look at
bishop 2e6 or if you see them
disregarding this all together and maybe
counter-attacking themselves
something like bishop to c5 we're going
to go over that as well
the first variation we are going to look
at is knight 2 h6 defending the square
here on
f7 and some players really don't like to
bring their queen
involved into the game too earlier
especially something like queen to e7
as it does block off the bishop here on
f8
makes it more difficult for black to
ever castle on the king side
and so knight to h6 makes some sense as
far as how they want to
defend this and now white's going to
play d3
this does a few things yes it opens up
the door for the dark square bishop if
you're curious why not
up here to d4 d3 also
threatens the square here on e4 at some
point white really wants to play
knight to f3 and if your opponent just
has your pawn
hanging out here on e4 for the rest of
the game it's pretty annoying so d3
does attack the center of the board
white can definitely take here on e4
if black at some point does not want to
take this material here on
d3 but white's also open to just giving
up material as with some gambits you're
okay giving up more than just a pawn
for a stronger attack and that's the
exact same thing that you're gonna see
in this gambit as well
if they decide to take that is fine
with us we're gonna go ahead and take
with our bishop here on
h6 if they take that has now removed the
defender of this evans
f7 square so white can come in take with
the bishop here on
f7 and then the king is forced to move
and has two options if they come here to
d7
kudos to us for laying a trap here
because that's going to be checkmate so
that's definitely the worst of the two
options for black
if they play king to e7 uh then knight
to f3 and you can start to see
this is a pretty fantastic board state
for white we don't even care too much
about this pawn on d3
i can play knight to c3 castle on the
king side
there's an exposed king here on e7 the
bishop here on f8 is blocked from that
none of the other material is involved
into the game at all so this should be a
very fun game for sure
from white standpoint just attacking
this exposed king
now they may not take with their pawn
they could play queen to e7 just saying
hey once i do take on the next move i'm
going to have a discovered attack
on the king here and this is situation
where we're just going to go ahead and
take that pawn and that's fine and we
don't even
care if they take what their queen would
check we're gonna play knight to e2
and you can start to see black could
continue to gobble up material and that
is okay
we're gonna let this queen just move all
around
and white's going to continue
development developing material
even though they may give up a few pawns
so the queen can take here on
g2 that's fine rook here to
g1 protected by the knight here
black queen can gobble up more material
here on h2
and then bishop to f4 you can start to
see white getting pieces involved into
the game
attacking material here and the material
is just going to have to
continue to move so queen to h4 and then
knight to c3
you can see black has two pieces
developed but knight here on h6 not
really the square that black wants his
knight
the queen on h4 it has done some damage
as far as taking up pawns but you look
from white's standpoint
there's a lot of material involved into
the game
this is pretty good for white here if
you look at
black's threats well okay this pawn here
on f2 is exposed
by this queen here attacking it so they
could play bishop to c5
just trying to continue their attacks
uh but now white just has castle on the
queen side
doesn't really care too much about this
threat anymore maybe the bishop takes
here on f2 but then
rook to h1 attacking the queen the queen
comes to g4
white can take material on h6 if the
pawn takes
then knight to d5 gets pretty scary from
black standpoint threatening coming up
here to
c7 still have the exposed pawn here on
f7 at some point so a lot of attacking
lines that white has in this position
if we come back a few moves instead of
the bishop coming down the c5 to attack
the pawn on f2
maybe instead they just play bishop to
e7 getting ready to castle on the king
side but you can probably see that that
exposes the pawn here on a g7 that white
can go ahead and take here
if they don't play bishop to e7 they
could also play
knight to sea sex just trying to get
material involved into the game
but now knight to d5 still that threat
coming up here to
c5 or c7 and even if they play bishop to
d6
protecting this white can still just
take and after the exchange
knight to c7 check this is forking the
rook here on
a8
now after pawn to d3 we've already
looked at the pawn takes if queen here
to e7
we could also see bishop to c5 just
attacking our weak square
here on f2 but that's completely fine
because we can take
that knight here on h6 and then after
they take
again we're removing that defender of
the f7 square so we can hop
in with bishop to f7 remember king to
d7 is going to be checkmate so hopefully
they do that but they probably won't the
best move for them would be king
to uh f8 king to e7 just going to get
more exposed
more central definitely not what the
black king wants to do but after king
2f8
we have knight to c3 here getting
another piece involved into the game
attacking this pawn here in the center
white king castle on the king side if
this pawn ever moves then knight to
f3 so a lot of attacking lines that
white has
in this position as well you can see
that white's
really trying to get a lot of material
involved into the game
attacking the exposed king and just
continuously putting pressure
on the opponent
next version we are going to look at is
queen 2e7
probably better if they protect the pawn
here on f7 with their queen instead of
the knight but it's always good to
understand what
you should do if your opponent plays
certain things so queen e7 while this
does protect it it also
blocks off the bishop here on f8 and so
they could play knight to f6
simple development move but it still
leaves the king
unable to castle on the king's side
now in this case because the queen is
here on e7
i do like to move knight to c3 uh before
d3 because
uh in some situations white has knight
to d5
and this does attack the queen so it's
very different where we'll go over in
just a minute where if the queen's here
on d7
i don't think that knight to c3 makes as
much sense as the first move but
queen to e7 knight to c3 and then we
have lots of variations that black could
play from here knight to f3
okay now we're going to play pawn to d3
if they take we're just playing bishop
here to e3
uh we do need to protect our king that
would be a discovered check with the
queen here on
uh e7 and now from here maybe knight to
c6 uh knight to f3
if they do something uh like uh bishop
to e3 and then d2
just trying to get our king more central
exposed
i would just go ahead and play f1 we can
get this material back if we want to at
some point
but you definitely don't want to get
your king in the center of the board in
this spot
you really want to be bringing your rook
over here with your king knot there so
if you want to attack this long
d file you can because remember they're
king on e8
probably not going to be castling to the
king side anytime soon
so having that in the center with more
attacking pieces for white
is going to be good now if they don't
play knight to f6
uh they could play knight to c6
now the difference here is white can
play knight to f5
or d5 they couldn't before because the
knight was here on f6 but it can
now it's attacking the queen it's also
attacking the pawn here on
c7 uh there's only two squares that
black can go to to defend that that
could play
queen to e5 uh and now we're just gonna
play d3
and then if they take we're playing
bishop here to e3 preparing for
knight to f3 attacking the queen here
if they instead play queen back to d8
that's fine same thing d3 and if they
take now knight to
f3 don't have to worry about bishop here
to e3 yet
if instead of bringing the knights out
they could play bishop to e6
but this does expose this pawn here on
b7
so the queen can just take here on uh b7
maybe they take our bishop that's fine
we're gonna take their rook here on a8
and you can see the knights being pinned
down
so they can't move their knight they
could always move their queen back but
they could also bring their queen to b4
which does also protect the knight here
on b8
so that's an option but then their pawn
on
e4 is going to be taken and this is also
uh check last option we're going to look
at in this variation
is if they play c6 preparing for
pawn to b5 uh just trying to get this
light squared bishop
off of the c4 square because it's
putting so much pressure
on this f7 square and black really wants
to alleviate some of that pressure
eventually get the dark square bishop
involvement of the game castle on the
king side
from here same thing d3
they could ignore this right away and
just play b5 and this is a very
important
move that you need to understand because
you can probably see that d3 does
block in the light square bishop white
needs to take with the knight here on
b5 and after they take it's important
not to recapture because if you take
with your bishop
you just gave up a knight and then they
can just play bishop to d7
and black is winning what you need to do
instead if they play
pawn takes here on b5 which they
probably will probably going to take the
knight that you're giving them
is you play bishop to d5 and you can
start to see some of the threats that
you have here obviously the main one
have rook taking here on a8
but even if they start to try to block
this in any fashion
they just don't have any good move so
that's how you're going to respond
if they're traded at c6 and then b5 push
the next variation we're going to look
at is queen to d7
still defending the square here on f7
now it's blocking off the light square
bishop from getting involved into the
game
we're gonna play d3 they have a few
options they don't have to take it but
they definitely can if they take right
here we're playing knight to f3 getting
this involved into the game as soon as
that pawn leaves the e4 square
maybe now they play knight to f6 just
trying as fast as possible to castle on
the king side now that the queen
is not blocking off the stark square
bishop but now it's real tough
because white's next move is going to be
rook to e1
if they play bishop to e7 well now
white has knight to e5 attacking the
queen here on d7 and the knights
bishop and queen are all attacking the
f7 square that's not going to go well
for black
but if the bishop goes anywhere else
rook to e1 and
really the bishop may just have to come
back here to e7 there's not only good
moves for
the bishop right here maybe they played
knight 2
c6 but same problem rook to e1 how did
they really protect it
bishop to e7 bishop takes on f7
this isn't going to be good if instead
they try to block it with their knight
if their thought was knight to c6
knight to e7 well then knight to g5
this is not going to go well for black
the knight bishop and queen all
attacking this pawn here on f7
the rook pinning down at the knights
right here
and even same thing if the king comes to
d8 yes
it removes this thread here on the e
file
but you still have knight to g5 you have
to worry about it's gonna put a lot of
pressure on the square on f7
knight coming here to f7 check this is
forking the rook right here the knight's
protected by the bishop and the queen
so it's really going to be difficult for
black in that position
if we come back they don't have to take
with their pawn here
on d3 if they don't take they could just
play knight to f6
develops a piece defends the pawn here
on
e4 in that case we're going to go and
play knight to c3
get as much material involved into the
game as possible
now if they want to go ahead and take
that's fine we're going to play knight
to
f3 if they don't maybe from this
position they play
knight to c6 okay well now we're just
going to go ahead and take
this pawn right here pretty much all
moves
if they don't take our pawn we're gonna
take their pawn right here so
same thing with uh bishop to d6
preparing to castle on the king side
we're gonna go and take with our pawn
right here hopefully eventually setting
up a fork at some point
here on e5 but then knight to f3 castle
on the king side get our durascore
bishop involved into the game
that is going to be the game plan if
they don't play knight to f6
they could also play bishop to d6 pretty
much any move they're gonna play
not taking our pawn here on d3 we're
just gonna take with our own pawn right
here white's equalized in material both
sides down
two pawns but you can see black has no
center pawns
white has a very strong pawn here on the
e4 square
all their pieces can get involved into
the game very easily this light square
bishop for black is still blocked by the
queen right here
white can play knight to f3 castle on
the king side so as far as development
this is a very solid structure for white
and this all stems from the french
defense which usually black's trying to
solidify the pawns in the center of the
board and really block
off a lot of attacking lines especially
these light square diagonals here for
white
white's completely blown that planet for
black and so they're definitely gonna
have to be thinking about something
different than they thought
when they started out with the french
defense
next variation we're going to look at is
bishop 2e6
just trying to put a stop to this attack
here on the long light square diagonal
i can just go ahead and take with the
bishop right here main thing is after
the pawn
takes to not capture here on e6 it may
look tempting
to go ahead and take here put the
opponent in check but white actually has
a better move
and that is queen taking here on b7
because really they need to be playing
knight to d7
not going to play knight to c6 this is
gonna lose the knight this is
attacking both the rook the king and the
pawn here on e4
so they're really going to be playing
knight to d7 and after this then the
queen takes here on
e4 so white gobble up two pawns
in material then black still has an
exposed king the square here on f7 has
been captured
and white has a pretty good board state
they will want to push forward with
their d-pawn
get their other pieces involved into the
game uh the the light square bishop and
the queen have been doing most of the
work so
not as active as the other pieces that
we've seen in the other variations for
white but you can see
that they are now up in material and
should have a pretty good game the rest
of the way
before we get into the last variation if
you haven't already
if you wouldn't mind please hitting the
like button
just takes one second but definitely
helps out the channel
a lot of people have been supporting all
of these opening videos around the game
it's
like to see the in-depth analysis on how
we can play these crazy gambits
but definitely would appreciate the
support also lets me know that you hate
playing against the french defense as
much as
i do so with that we'll get into the
last variation that is
if they just completely ignore this f7
square maybe bishop to c5 just says hey
i'm going to attack your your weak
square here on f2
definitely a mistake to not pay
attention to the f7 square because we
are
absolutely taking on f7 if they are not
going to protect it
we've already shown that king to d7 is a
problem because that's going to be
checkmate for white so hopefully they do
that
if they actually fall for that please
let me know because that would be
awesome i haven't got someone to fall
for the king to d7 but
it's coming it's definitely coming so
they could play king to f8 we can just
continue to gobble up material here
maybe knight to e2 preparing to castle
on
the king side uh you can see white's
equalized immaterial but
all day long i'm taking white's position
here
because the king here on f8 is extremely
exposed
uh and white can just start to attack
the rest of the game so that
is my favorite way to attack the french
defense
the ortho schnapp gambit definitely play
this
let me know what you guys think there
are some other variations that we didn't
go
over as far as the decline line also
just the french defense early on
if you guys want to see some additional
videos maybe
after c4 d5 and then if we take here if
you want to see a video on
e5 or just the pawn taking on d5
i could definitely make those videos as
well let me know in the comments
what you want to see in future videos
but thank you guys so much for watching
and i'll see you in the next video
you